you don't know your passion coz you
haven't done [ __ ] Billy how much [ __ ]
have you actually done yet not much my
man so like you got to go try [ __ ] not
just Billy all your [ __ ] like yeah
you're just happy you're more Billy you
got your perspective so this is just a
fun fun morning for me a couple things
I'm gonna shoot it a little bit here
give a little context but the reality is
I want to take advantage of the fact
that we're actually here together and so
I'll create a little bit of a framework
but I'd love to do as much QA as
possible so if anything of stuff you've
seen or context you've had in the past
or anything I touch on here you know I
think the QA part is the most valuable
thing I think you know I think about
leverage a lot and so the biggest thing
that I think about when I'm in this room
especially for all the kids in the room
for ninety five percent 90 percent of
you right now maybe the most leverage
you ever have and I want to start there
because it's super important to me when
I think about being a college athlete in
in a place where the sport is so looked
at you know the truth is the percentage
of people that are in this room that go
on to the league and make enough money
in the league to take care of their
whole life is remarkably low just it's
just [ __ ] remarkably low meanwhile
you know I keep thinking about this
former Louisville safety that played for
the Jets for a couple years and I deemed
him a couple times on Twitter and talked
to some of his homies and I kept saying
the same thing which is you know I would
hit him up because I'm a Jets fan and he
would and his homies would hit me up
because they knew what I was doing an
entrepreneurship but we never connected
we never he never made the time to chop
it up and I remember one time I deemed
him when it was very clear to me that
his career was gonna be short and I
literally just DM them said yo bro
you're [ __ ] up because right now
I'm dying to have an hour with you in a
world where people pay $100,000 to have
an hour with me and in a couple of
months you're gonna get cut and I have
no time to [ __ ] even reply to you cuz
the leverage you have with the logo
right now is my biggest passion in the
world and the day you don't work where
that logo I don't give a [ __ ] about you
and the reality is that's exactly what
happened and then he hit me up nine
months later and because I'm a good dude
I replied but with a reply of I've got
no time for you and that's how I think
about this not to come harsh or
what-have-you
I just know because I'm a Jersey boy and
I know the business world and the world
that there's a [ __ ] load of people that
are Rutgers alums that are super
interested in you right now and the
second you don't have that big R on your
chest they're not and how to balance
bless you and how to balance that with
academics with film work with practice
with you and what you're doing here is
super interesting to me because it's a
fine line right one of the biggest
things I hear from a lot of coaches both
actually all three levels high school
professional and college is kids
especially with what I talk about and
what I want for you is like how do we
find that balance to let kids build
their brand on social and marketing I
think everybody in this room knows you
know the thing that worked out for me as
somebody who loves athletes is 20 years
ago athletes didn't give a [ __ ] about
entrepreneurs now the top hundred
athletes in the world are DMing me on a
consistent basis so it's crazy to watch
entrepreneurship blow up even when you
guys were kids even as young as you are
you know that this entrepreneur thing is
really just 5-10 years old where people
really really [ __ ] with it heavy and so
you know to me finding that balance of
how you leverage where you are in your
life right now while staying focused is
the number one thing I come into this
morning on because the reality is I want
you to leverage it because I want your
life to be happy and and for me I think
it starts in a couple of places so the
biggest thing that I've observed when
I've talked to teams and now speak
speaking to a lot of kids the top top
for me is how many people in this room
when they go to class or on campus
are in a place where their headphones in
focus on their [ __ ] given that you have
the leverage right now and the reality
is the kids around you that want to say
what's up are gonna have the leverage in
a decade I think about this every day I
think about like I always you know it's
funny when I when I talk I was think
about it's funny to have AJ here by
having a brother who's 11 years younger
I kind of got a lot of practice early to
like spit wisdom or try to be a mentor I
think about what I would tell AJ if he
was dramatically more athletic and was
sitting in this room and and I would say
like yo bro like you know this is just
the math around it yet there's a hundred
people on campus right now who are gonna
be the biggest CEOs or players in New
York City in seven years and right now
they're dying to take a selfie with you
but you have no time because you might
be caught up that you have the leverage
right now and that's the biggest mistake
it's the biggest myth I call it the high
school girl rule right a lot of people
didn't want to talk to certain girls in
high school but six years later they
really want to talk to them but they
[ __ ] up the leverage because they were
a dick in high school and I think about
that a lot and I think a lot of you are
in that position right now please don't
underestimate or take for granted
obviously if you're in this room you
know for the far majority of you you had
leverage in high school - from your
athletics and so you're used to that by
now whether it's one two three four five
six seven years that leverage is
everything in society it's crazy I watch
it every day
the whole social media thing watching
the biggest most famous people in our
society only five to seven years ago be
slow to Instagram because they thought
they were fancy and they were
celebrities so they didn't go on and
they made fun of Instagram models and
they made fun of Instagram comedians and
they made fun of people and now where
that is the currency and they're not on
it
just watching the most famous people in
our society grabbing at straws hitting
me up of like how do I do this when just
five years ago they had all the leverage
and now we forgot who they were or don't
give a [ __ ] it's fascinating that is
where you're at right now for a lot of
you this is the most leverage you will
ever have
how you figure out how to use that to
connect with people which are the only
leverage in actual life it's probably
the biggest thing that I want to get
across its it think about it so much a
couple other things coach without
knowing all the rules of how you think
about social what have you so take it
for what it's worth communicating and
engaging with people is enormous and
again you know I come anytime I go into
somebody's living room I come with
massive respect right make sure you take
your shoes off make sure you don't step
on [ __ ] like you know I you know I think
about it so I come here with a lot of
respect but if you find time to balance
your time you know I always think about
like instead of that hour on fortnight
or Call of Duty or 2k if that kid at
that university spends 20 minutes
replying to people on Twitter who are
talking about their school's program in
that sport what that actually means in
life I think people are very confused
about serendipity and communication like
literally just go into Twitter search or
go into Instagram and searching hashtags
and putting Rutgers football somebody
says they're excited for the Iowa game
and you say thanks it just blows my mind
that that is actually your internship
that is actually your career I think
about that every day I see it every day
and I see it with kids that follow me
that don't have leverage the way you
have it that are just doing it randomly
hoping yet you've got all the leverage
that they are actually super interested
in what you do right now so to me that
you know it's funnier I was driving here
this morning I was like what I want to
what do I want to get off what I want to
make sure they know and and that's it
like you know I was trying to conjure up
like a second a third a fourth thing to
take up the time and I'll do that I'll
improv on you right now but the number
one thing if I leave this morning that I
hope is for people to realize how much
leverage they have how you just like
weight room and film you've got to put
in work to get what you want and how
what social media on the internet have
done is given you so much opportunity to
take advantage of who you engage with
around what you want
you know if you just deployed the
leverage you have and the way you think
about sliding into DMS on girls with it
if you just deployed that strategy to
business and life on social media
the reality is the far majority of you
would get so much more ROI of the number
you have on your back right now for the
next year to three years it's crazy and
it's real it's crazy and it's real a
couple other things I want to talk about
I'm real passionate about patience I
think the biggest vulnerability to this
room including the coaches and us old
guys is patience
I wish the coaches over here knew how
young they were watching 30 40 50 year
olds completely confused by the context
of time is one of the most fascinating
things I see in our society like people
always come up to me and I Gary when you
gonna buy the Jets and I'm like 25 years
and they get sad as [ __ ] like they think
they like want me to have it tomorrow
and I'm like I just don't build wealth
like that I'm just like one brick at a
time I'm not gambling out here or hoping
or dreaming I already [ __ ] up by
passing on uber twice in the angel round
that would have made me my billion so I
missed that shot so the reality is is
that I'm just building blocks and so you
know whether you deploy this what I'm
talking about right now - like how
you're thinking about cracking the
starting lineup or why you're pissed
you're on special teams but you should
be starting or whatever [ __ ] excuses
you come up with in your own head the
reality is patience as an overlay is
remarkably important it's remarkably
important like you're gonna be done with
school you're gonna be a professional
whether in the league or CFL or XFL or
whatever your major is or your passion
is or entrepreneurship you're gonna be
done here do whatever I just said for 10
more years and then be 32 and young as
[ __ ] and the reality is you have no
concept of that now because you can't
because the way time works in our brains
I remember when I got out of school I
couldn't wait in Springfield New Jersey
not far from here either
to work in the wine store and blow it up
like I said I was going to and I did
and I remember walking in my cousin
worked you know this family business my
cousin my dad's first cousin worked
there but the way their grandparents
were he was closer in age to me than my
dad we're in between actually he was 30
and I was 22 and I remember that first
month working with him every day I was
like this guy's oldest [ __ ] and he was
30 and I'm 43 right now thinking about
how you're thinking about my age versus
yours and I feel young as [ __ ] right and
I think about that I'm like how the hell
do I communicate that to kids that
you're gonna live like I'm double the
age of the majority of you double you're
gonna live an entire another [ __ ]
life and still have your whole life in
front of you yet everybody's impatient
as [ __ ] shortcuts so it kills everybody
it just does shortcuts because you
decided in your own head focus group of
one that you deserve something think
about that a lot and I think about that
in athletics a lot and I see it commonly
people start cutting corners getting
themselves into trouble by not putting
in the work or doing dumb [ __ ] or
whatever [ __ ] it is because it for it
listen four of your friends in your dorm
are from back home gassing you up but
what's supposed to be happening versus
what's happening is the biggest mistake
everybody makes and the amount of head
stares you shook their head makes me
feel excited that I hit that point four
or five people your family or friends
are from back home or who you're in the
quad with gassing you up by the way it
should be versus the way it is is the
biggest vulnerability athletes have
entrepreneurs have businesspeople have I
just see that parents see it every day
results speak and the reality is coaches
have that subjective call you might be
right they just might like a skill set
from somebody else a little bit more in
the way it works on the overall or who
knows or maybe most likely which I see a
ton they just don't like the way you're
handling it so to me I would rip both my
arms and legs off to be as fortunate as
you are to be at this age during the
Internet's maturity at this age
I'd probably own the Jets by now if I
was lucky enough to have the Internet
at this age the remarkable nature of
that machine and everybody [ __ ] on
it now for hate and all the fucked-up
things that people think social media
isn't changing us social media is
exposing us it's not instagrams fault
it's not Twitter's fault you you're
angry or you hate it's your fault these
platforms are exposing us and so I
really highly recommend you figure out
your relationship with these powerful
platforms because regardless of what
anybody's opinions are of them they will
be the currency of our society for a
very long time you figuring out how to
use it let me give you a couple things
about social that might matter for
somebody who's out there and is getting
judged because one thing I have so much
respect for you guys is regardless of
how great you are you've got multiple
moments of people booing you at scale
right like like one thing I love about
athletes is if if they get to the right
place mentally they're in a place where
they're always ready to get booed I
think the reason I'm super successful is
because I got booed my whole life I was
an immigrant couldn't speak English got
booed I was a [ __ ] terrible student a
couple miles away from here got booed
right
I'm smallest [ __ ] and not good enough at
sports got booed
I got booed at everything which may be a
great entrepreneur because I'm ready to
get booed I love being booed I love else
the reason I love the Jets and Knicks so
much is they have a one [ __ ] I grew up a
huge Yankees and Rangers fan as soon as
they want a title I was out I'm about to
climb I loved losses I love pain I'm
serious I love it and so I think once
you figure out how to mentally embrace
taking out but real quick on that front
on social I watched so many kids that
I'm looking at watching them progress
have a terrible game throw for picks
delete their [ __ ] delete it hit me up on
DM I'm gonna Gary Vee I'm gonna detox
off insta I know we've been talking but
like off this this game last week I'm
done I'm coming back in October and I
always think about that [ __ ] and we all
have to figure out our relationship with
technology but here's how I take it from
my purview I think people get too high
when they get cheered
I think the reason people struggle when
people [ __ ] on them in comments is
because they're taking other people's
opinions way too serious
the best way to be able to help take
care of and deal with people [ __ ] on
you is not getting too high when they're
giving you accolades when I watch videos
like that when people give right now I'm
on that place where I get so much love I
don't hear them I really don't I
understand I appreciate it feels
humbling as [ __ ] you know but I don't
hear him I still think I suck I'm
grinding I'm in the process it's early
which is why when people [ __ ] on me and
they do a lot because when you're out
there like that that's just how it is I
can't hear them either and so one thing
one thing I would consider is actually
using social medias negativity and
judgment as an ability to actually
absorb it create a framework where you
can actually accept both pros and cons
at scale instead of running away from it
every time I see somebody shutting down
and deleting I get nervous because I
don't see it as a detox for 99% of the
people I talked to I see it running away
from judgment and judgment is the only
thing I promise you that you'll have for
the rest of your life and that you have
had so I'm offense you know this might
be to an old school of a of a sports
reference but some of the coaches might
remember this back in the day there was
a really famous basketball college team
Loyola Marymount that had Hank Gathers
who unfortunately passed away during a
game it was real crazy in the culture
back in 89 but every time I think about
that team it's how I think about my life
and how I think about myself as an
entrepreneur they were when college
basketball games like 147 to 132 they
were just running shoot they were just
they just pushed it their games were
crazy and I think about life I think too
many people are playing defense I think
too many people are trying to win like
the 94 Knicks like 79 to 76 and I'm out
here trying to win 149 to 146 offense
because once you stop hearing judgment
and you're not actually worried about
what people have to say you can just go
fast
you start doing [ __ ] do you know how
many of you right now in this room have
a real passion for some [ __ ] that isn't
cool right now and so you're just not
doing it yet it's exactly the right
thing the amount of friends I had back
in the day that loved video games but
got off of it because they didn't see a
career for it or even at one time
believe it or not video games was dorky
[ __ ] who now regret at 40 because they
were [ __ ] great at it and they could
be the Tony Hawk of eSports right now
they could have been that og but they
just didn't see it because they were
worried about judgment and they didn't
realize the world evolved that gets a
Myint to my final point and then we can
get into real specific questions
whatever your PAP you know the biggest
eye-opener for AJ going into the
football business like as hardcore fans
as we've been as how close we've been to
teams and owners the owner to Miami
Dolphins is our is my business partner
like as close as I've been to it now
that I'm really really in it I just
can't believe how many of you don't
fully love the game it's just your
ticket it's just your process it's
amazing I don't I don't throw that as
judgment I think that's [ __ ] fresh
like it makes sense to me like I love it
so much and I so wish I could write that
I was naive and did what I always make
fun of people like focus group of one it
has been eye-opening to how many people
actually don't love it they were just
blessed see I got real real real lucky
they're lucky as [ __ ] on earth is the
thing you love is the thing that you're
best at and I think that's me like I
liked when I was six I wanted to wash
people's cars when it snowed and we had
snow days here I was shoveling snow not
making snowmen right like like literally
I don't know how many of you follow me
but if you see what I'm doing in garage
saleing around here in Jersey like I'm
not doing that for show I [ __ ] love
it like I'd rather wake up on Saturday
at 6:00 in the morning and drive to
[ __ ] you know McCutchen's town-wide
garage sale and buy some [ __ ] for a
dollar and sell it for 11 bucks on eBay
that [ __ ] gives me way bigger of a
high then [ __ ] almost anything
besides watching a Jets game that is
literally probably my favorite thing
except a Sunday in the fall and so that
gets me to my final point if you're
sitting here right now and you're real
real [ __ ] passionate about something
doesn't have to do with the four walls
were in right now you need to lean into
that [ __ ] because that's the thing the
Internet's doing the amount of people
that can make a real living around
having a podcast or a vlog or flipping
[ __ ] they love versus getting a job they
[ __ ] hate and they can make as much
or around the same much around having a
[ __ ] podcast around fortnight versus
going and working in finance cuz they in
turn this summer in Wall Street and I
think that's where the money is that
[ __ ] I know nobody here believes but
I've been saying it for a decade and I'm
watching it every day and it's real and
so I highly recommend like I'm really
hopeful like honestly when I come just
to put into context including the left
side here when I come to these rooms
honestly I'm real realistic I'm just
hoping to penetrate one head one dome
I'm aware that like I'll come in will be
good talk and be cool you know if some
friends don't think I'm cool you think
uncle it's great I'm hoping but I'm God
I'm hoping to get through one person's
head on some of these things because I
know I see [ __ ] that other people don't
that's been my calling card and so I
hope you've been really listening I
really do and I hope we can like add on
to like like right now what I'm trying
to set up for the coaches to like I'm
trying to set up context I'd love to
like by the way if you have context I
mean like what to invest in next how do
I grow my fault like I want to create
what I'm doing on this little rant it's
permission and safety for you to ask
your actual question that's running
through your head because I think the
Q&A part at least two three or four
times I've done this has always been the
part that really has brought the most
value and I want to bring value so damn
it sucked that bad I get that home kid
so yeah thank you for having me I really
appreciate it
I left a lot of time for Q&A like the
three or four times I've done this with
teams pro and and in college like let's
go with it so check me right like like
I'm putting out a hundred pieces of
content a day right like I'm really at
the tippy-top right now and there's not
a [ __ ] photo of my family or kids on
the internet like I don't share more
than half my life what I would say is
you control it that's what's great about
social versus the media star-ledger is
gonna say what the [ __ ] they want
you control none of that you control
your social now you may not want to show
anything and I'm cool with that too but
you're your PR agent on that platform
now don't confuse that with being full
of [ __ ] on it because people will sniff
that out
everybody's faking it to the make I mean
people are doing all sorts of crazy [ __ ]
on Instagram like jumpin fences at
private private plane places biggest
problem right now is people jump in
fences to take a photo acting like they
took a private flight so that shit's
never gonna work
cuz everybody look you saw Bow Wow get
exposed like people get exposed don't go
there back but but the good news is if
you're introverted and quiet it's cool
like like first of all you don't have to
do it at all let's just start right
there just cuz there's an opportunity
doesn't mean you got to do something
there's an opportunity to make a
fuckload of money going to garage sales
in New Jersey every Saturday doesn't
mean you have to but it's real big and
and my big thing is like especially like
if I left here and then like AJ hit me
up in October and said hey man you've
lit a real flame and like what do you
mean he's like man half the football
team is replying to everybody on Twitter
about Rutgers football that would be
amazing because that would really work
just thank you you know a lot of people
can't think of what to say a lot of
times just thank you thanks for
supporting us appreciate it you know so
urine could
trol don't do some [ __ ] cuz I said so
it's all self-awareness however you're
in control right so if you don't want
people know your business nobody wants
that that's the beauty of being able to
control it you control your part you
can't control somebody taking a picture
when you're out that's just the world we
live in but you can control what you
have to say and what picture you want to
paint yes but make sure it's truth you
said even food and build tons of times
in your life yeah but every business
failures the side of it you know my
failures were funny because I'm an
immigrant so I've always gotten that I
never do [ __ ] that's like gonna put me
totally out of business I always it got
a nest egg I'm always on like three and
a half be like I'm never doing something
that's like over the edge and if this
[ __ ] up it's like you know my biggest
mistakes have been the things I haven't
done I referenced it real quick if you
go read my first book in 2008 crush it
2008 I thanked my family and one random
person
Travis Cal connect who went on to start
use to when me and AJ started
vaynermedia used to fly around like in
Vegas and [ __ ] and just hang out with us
cuz he had no job he was in between
starts
uber I'm investing like crazy on
everything he asked me to invest in uber
twice and I said no because I just
bought an apartment I was a little less
liquid I thought it was a side project
for him I so thought ooh BRR was like a
rich man's game like it was originally
like a limo on your phone so I was like
you know how big is that gonna be and I
passed twice we got in a little bit
later you know so we did all right but
but I mean I let I mean if I wrote my
normal fifty thousand twenty five
thousand dollar check I probably left in
the ballpark of three hundred to eight
hundred million on the table so that's
an L
and on some real [ __ ] like I don't even
feel it because what I've started to
really learn about myself in the last
year or so is I'm about the process not
the trophies I'm just about the process
I love my game I love my game so much I
want to win I'd like to have that w but
uh money's funny right like anybody who
doesn't have it thinks it's the key to
happiness and they're super confused and
then they say well easy for you to say
you have and I was like you know I
didn't have it for a long-ass time I
lived in the villas in Springfield
Avenue in Springfield and a [ __ ] [ __ ]
apartment and I was 28 buying nothing
making 40 50 thousand a year working
[ __ ] 90 hours a week in a liquor
store so I've tasted both so I made a
lot of mistakes I pass on all sorts of
[ __ ] I just don't know what the mistakes
are cuz I say no so much cuz I'm so
[ __ ] busy what if that one meeting
was what you know make a lot of mistakes
man
so when pitching to investors Tyler the
biggest mistake all the kids are making
now is their pandering to the VC so the
whole deck is made with like you know
what you know what it is if you're
asking me this question every number
you're gonna pitch me you're making up
right you have some finance kid or
parents or you looked up on the internet
of how to project numbers it's all
projections and people sniff out
[ __ ] so my advice is going real as
[ __ ] and be like you know I really want
to make this company I have no idea I
can give you here here here's a slide
that says and year one will lose a
million year two will lose five million
year three you know but like shooting it
straight with investors I think really
really really is a countermove right now
because in my game and the investment
world like people just full of [ __ ]
everybody thinks that are found the
biggest reason I stopped investing in
the last three years and do it like once
or twice a year is back in oh six when I
the first three think the first three
companies I invested in were Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr that was easy for me
because I believed in social media and
the kids were actually founders because
they were nerds like straight nerds like
real nerd [ __ ] now it flipped now the
coolest thing you can be is a [ __ ]
founder now an entrepreneur sits with a
rapper and an athlete so now everybody
is one because entrepreneurship is
hidden you know what's amazing about
sports and rap it's not hidden you could
tell me you're the best
but the [ __ ] merit of the game is
gonna spit it out you could tell me you
[ __ ] got the best [ __ ] flow and you
can spit it but the markets gonna decide
on Soundcloud and Spotify
entrepreneurship people are hiding like
yo I'm a founder they put that [ __ ] in
or Instagram CEO and they're not doing
jack [ __ ]
you could be an entrepreneur being a
successful entrepreneur it takes time to
weed out so real direct honesty real
direct honesty like I don't know in a
pitch or I'm not sure is the number one
thing because I take meetings just to
stay fresh just to do favors and I laugh
when I ask questions that I know the
answer to and they try to front and I'm
like game over
my man what's your name
CJ
yeah give me a starting point cuz the
the biggest reason I got into the garage
sale flipping thing is so many people
like yo Gary I want to make more money
and what they're really saying is how do
I make as much money as fast as possible
that's what people really say like yo I
got a thousand but I need four thousand
I got ten thousand I want a hundred
thousand and they want it quicker
because like for example if you've got
any money and you want to be investor go
buy Facebook and Amazon and Netflix
stock because the next five seven nine
years they'll be better there you go
but nobody wants to buy something at 200
bucks a share and in five years it's 300
a share but it's guaranteed it's better
than putting it on red or black on the
flip side the quickest way I know how to
make money from like a small base under
ten thousand bucks like a hundred bucks
is flip life flip life bro do you
understand that if you went to the
[ __ ] Walmart or Target close by and
just scan [ __ ] on your eBay app and
Amazon app you could find arbitrage
something that's on the clearance aisle
at Target at twenty five bucks that
sells on ebay for 60 bucks but you know
what everybody says but what about the
fuel what about the eBay costs what
about the work for me how to ship it and
I always reply yeah work better no more
can I [ __ ] whitecastle
for six bucks an hour so on some real
[ __ ] to flipping is crazy like going to
Goodwill and buying a Jersey for two
bucks and 70 cents and selling it for 19
we're 25 on Facebook marketplace or eBay
or postmarked you know flipping I'm
[ __ ] pushing it hard because it's
real and the best part is like when I
look at this like you just have to be
willing to see my my biggest advantages
I'm dirty I'm dirty I don't give a [ __ ]
what people think do you know we people
when I put out these garage sale videos
my homies in Silicon Valley and
Hollywood and Wall Street like players
RDMA me [ __ ] like half a more like this
is the best [ __ ] I've ever seen but half
a more like you know you're making
yourself look stupid I'm like - who
do you [ __ ] you serious - what you're
judging me you're [ __ ] it I think
it's stupid that you're golfing for nine
hours age I know you love God myself
like you know like I don't want to golf
[ __ ] you Malibu Don you're surfing
I can't surf [ __ ] that [ __ ] it's stupid
I don't always for hours trying to surf
I want to go to somebody's [ __ ]
garage like I did a couple months ago
and buy a bunch of Olympic pins for 20
bucks and flipped my me Bay for 4000 I
bet a bunch of people here only got 20
bucks be pumped as [ __ ] to turn into
4,000 on some hours that you wasted
playing 2k and listening to the baby's
album ten times I [ __ ] love that guy
but the best part about music is you can
listen to [ __ ] the baby's [ __ ]
mixtape while you list that [ __ ] on eBay
how much dumb time you guys waste
professional athletes and college
busiest [ __ ] [ __ ] you you got time you
know you got time [ __ ] chasing skirts
and playing video games
put it work
that's a great question my biggest thing
and like if you like what how many
people here follow me on Instagram a
little bit so I really appreciate it so
you may know this I don't know if you've
noticed but in last six months to a year
I've been showing the old clips from ten
years ago when I was a little more
chubby had a little more hair little
blacker hair
and I'm doing that to show people bro
I've been doing this everyday for a
[ __ ] decade and only now I'm popping
so how do you do it
put out content of everything this is if
you start looking I'm laying out the
blueprint for you here right now how do
you do it the best way to build a brand
when you're [ __ ] remarkable athlete
that got to play [ __ ] v1 football is
to talk about your love for drama is to
talk about the fact that you love ice
cream is the fact that you like you're
really interested in wine or really
really good at old-school Nintendo or
really understand [ __ ] Southside
Atlanta rap and here's your opinion on
who's next
that's what I'm doing for the people
have been following me because I really
know a lot about hip hop like I'm
bringing gonna and Megg the Stalley and
all these people before they blow and
then everything everyone's like why is
that old white dude always know what's
happening Mike Boyd it's got his ear to
the street that's my guy but like
besides that so like I think the best
way to build your brand is to put [ __ ]
out on the Internet Facebook Twitter
start a vlog you know there's a kid at
the University of Texas Colin Johnson I
see having a blog as a receiver but you
know you see what he's like put a blog
but you got to do what's good for you
maybe two or three of you start a
podcast just record that [ __ ] on your
phone post it like you got to make you
got to do you know fun to talk to
athletes because a lot of my analogy and
business class is like you can't read
about push-ups you can [ __ ] watch
film all day until you put the work on
the field that's the game and that's how
I think about building your brand you
can come up with strategies you can read
all my books you can watch all my videos
but instill until you start putting out
videos and pictures and written words on
all these platforms you're doing nothing
what I'm trying to do is give you
permission to talk about the [ __ ] that's
really in your soul not what you're
supposed to be talking about give me a
three hundred pound offensive lineman in
college football starting to make
content about opera that
[ __ ] kids gonna blow up because it's
not what you expect so the thing you're
most into or the thing that you know the
most about putting out those posts you
can't imagine how much upside there is
about that my man I'm sorry my man one
more time I just don't give a [ __ ] about
what anybody thinks about me cuz they
don't know who the [ __ ] I am inside like
how can I value your opinion about me if
you don't know me like my mom knows me
the best in the world she's my hero
and she doesn't know everything about me
it's real easy to not let judgement come
in when you have empathy for the other
person and know they're just seeing a
clip of you or just one moment of time
they don't know you everybody slow
because they value other people's
opinions I just have no time for that
mainly on some weird [ __ ] you know what
I really I mean I was always that way
but where I went to a hundred was when
all these famous people started dying
and we gave a [ __ ] on Twitter for like a
day and then we don't give a [ __ ] no
more lot less people talking about my
man nipsey now that's only been a couple
months and it's just [ __ ] with me I'm
like man I'm trying to do it all these
things like we're just human beings like
my grandma passed a couple weeks ago and
like a bear deer in woodbridge and like
I don't know it's not on my mind that
much today that's just life so it got
real easy for me to like navigate
because I'm like what I'm really gonna
value somebody else's opinion about me
when they don't know I got one life you
know my friends you know how rare it is
to have a life the odds right now
currently that science accepts for the
odds of actually being alive is 400
trillion to 1 there's no [ __ ] you'll
ever do in your life that is more
ridiculous than the fact that you even
have one and people out here crying
about what they don't have or what's
[ __ ] up with society or what they
can't or what just complaining and the
biggest thing bro
nobody gives a [ __ ] like it sucks you
know both my grandfather's spent the
deck and one of my grandfather's spent
almost actually spent 10 years in jail
and once spent a couple months both for
just being Jewish in Russia you know and
like the reality of like my parents
grown up in the Soviet Union I realized
like nobody gives a [ __ ] right like
doesn't mean there isn't racism sexism
suppression it's just that what
like we're just in control of our [ __ ]
and that's how I think I'm in control of
my [ __ ] and I don't give a [ __ ] what you
think and I just go and so getting
through roadblocks is easy it's you know
there's this Creek how many people seen
rocky for the one with Drago
real quick just raise your hands real
quick I'm just curious for the reference
okay Rocky Ford Ford a couple of you
didn't raise your hand
Rocky's fighting the Russian dude he
goes to Russia he beats him right at the
end of it there's a scene that nobody
ever talks about I googled the [ __ ] but
for me I can't stop thinking about it
2530 years later at the end Drago loses
and he grabs the mic and this is when
the Cold War was going down like Russian
America hated each other
it's like terrorism now for America
right like real like [ __ ]
at the end he grabs the mic after he
took an L and he goes [ __ ] all of you
basically he goes I'm in the ring for me
this is my L not Russia's L to America
mine and that's how I think about this
[ __ ] I'm not worried about your judgment
when I lose that's my L I don't care
about your opinions of my L I would have
been a real good quarterback like next
play like I just don't care it doesn't
matter
I'll throw nine picks and still [ __ ]
win the game if you let me stay in you
know
like that's how I think that's how I
think as a human that's how I think as
an entrepreneur you know it's just like
I always think about like the things in
the mental makeup that I had that would
have made me really good at sitting here
it's like next [ __ ] play what people
boo and what coach is gonna yell at me
on Tuesday on film I don't have time for
that right now I got a [ __ ] next play
that's life nobody cares that your
[ __ ] mother was [ __ ] up nobody
cares where you came to nobody cares
like of course people care but they
can't do [ __ ] about it
you don't like it move go to Sweden yes
you know you know what's really thanks
for sending guys what what's super
devastating about when I hit Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr is I had very little
I had money because this is a good story
this might help you guys so I wasn't
making that much money in my 20s at the
liquor store I was pouring oil back into
building Wine Library so but even though
I was making like 60,000 55,000 63,000 I
was saving I was living like I was
making dirty and that's why I had a
little nest egg when I saw my moment I
struck that's where everybody [ __ ] up
everybody lives 25 to 100 percent more
than they have that credit card [ __ ]
game all by the way back to the last
question because they want to buy the
new Supremes to flex on Instagram for
people that they actually don't even
[ __ ] like it's the most [ __ ] up
framework keeping up with the Joneses is
[ __ ] broken people buying chains they
can't afford to look that means crazy
it's crazy so I was [ __ ] saving so my
comfort level was every dollar I had on
some [ __ ] I believed in I wasn't an
investor when I invested in those three
things I was just taking an opportunity
later when I became an investor and had
more money like a I got done I started
losing because my my level of comfort
was greater
right I was being looser you know like
when you go to the casino you want a
little something you got a little house
money gets stupid you change what got
you there and so that's what happened
there I would say your level of comfort
has to be it going to zero because 99%
of companies fail whatever you are super
thrilled to go and have disappear off
the face of the earth that's your number
especially when you all have a fuckload
even when you have a fuckload that's how
I bet now I'm rich now but I still bet
what a when I write that check I'm like
zero that's why I've never had a crazy
failure cuz a lot of people write a
check I'd like okay but this is gonna
get me to my million or my Maserati and
then they hope this is the worst [ __ ]
strategy of all time you like that one I
like that one too
yep well not when you hit roadblocks and
you know I don't want to [ __ ] you I
really didn't I was on a [ __ ] mission
like I didn't care my friend you know
like all my friends when I got into my
30s started getting some press [ __ ]
started happening everyone's like yo you
know cut you know I grew up when there
was like no internet so like I've high
school friends from Northland High
School in Harlan County started reaching
out to me saying like oh you're so lucky
or this ID like [ __ ] I'm not
lucky I'm like you remember [ __ ] in 1999
when you went to the Jersey Shore bang
chicks I [ __ ] worked so like I was
just in my [ __ ] cocoon bro like for
real you know like just in it and so
like I'm trying to get back to the point
that I was talking with my man like
roadblocks are self-imposed based on
judgment from other people think about
you know what this is perfect analogy
think about how many times you guys get
banged up on plays during games that so
many people would take themselves out
and not play at all oh it's [ __ ] hit
that you know when you get banked like
football's crazy
you guys are getting banged up on every
[ __ ] play and think about the
tolerant
you guys know you guys all know
everything you know the kid in this room
who gets chipped up a little bit and is
out and you know the person that's on
this team right now they'll break their
[ __ ] back and play but for normal
people like me I'm like every play would
get me out that's how I was as an
entrepreneur the [ __ ] that I think
people think of roblox do you know what
it feels like to be 26 years old have
people that you went to high school with
come to your liquor store look you dead
in the face as they pulled up in their
BMW and say oh you work for your dad and
then you ring them up on their case of
champagne that they're gonna use for
their party and you bring it out to
their car and put it in their trunk and
they look you in the face with pity I
lived that life and the way I took that
scene was I'll see you in ten years
[ __ ]
I mean just to get to where you are now
if we were your core values of course
that song to me no that was one clearly
I've established that I've established
that yeah gratitude on that four hundred
trillion to one thing I'm grateful
straight up like I don't know us to say
like you might have not been born right
like your dad could have been late to
the apartment that day like I'm some
real [ __ ] like I don't think people
would contextualize perspective like
what like you're live you could've been
a tree you could it like like right like
like this is cool like life is good like
it's cool to have one that's number one
being the big one of the biggest things
for me is being the bigger person I hate
conflict ironically like I'm a tough guy
when I have the mic and nobody else can
talk but in real life I like like
happiness and like vibes and like so
like I've eaten [ __ ] my whole life like
kids stole hundreds of thousands of
dollars for me in the liquor store like
like literally like I found a way for
him not to go to jail for a long time
like you know like just being the bigger
person has been a core principle of mine
not valuing money over family and like
happiness has been huge [ __ ] money like
really you can you can not care about
money more when you don't care about
what people think about your money you
know like you know so um do patience
like I've talked a lot of [ __ ] and I'm
sure a lot of people like gonna walk
away not giving a [ __ ] or flip life or
what-have-you like if you leave with
anything if I had my choice it would be
holy [ __ ] I'm gonna live for more full
lives and no matter how crazy what I
think about right now is and like what
do I want to accomplish on or off the
field like I got four [ __ ] life's to
do it like you guys know Grey Goose the
guy who invented that as an entrepreneur
invented it at 78 Sidney Frank 78 years
old you know
life is like sports like one of the
great moments of my life with AJ is the
Monday night miracle at the Meadowlands
with the Jets Dolphins that [ __ ] was
thirty to seven in the fourth quarter
and they won they came all the way back
my cousin left went home to Queens went
to sleep I called him when they tied it
at 30 and said can you believe the [ __ ]
he's already sleeping he left that game
and was already sleeping in Queens I was
like what are you talking about hung up
and then the Dolphins [ __ ] scored I
made it thirty seven thirty and we
[ __ ] blamed Bobby for waking up but
like that's life like you could do
everything wrong have every dream you've
ever had get [ __ ] up blame it on other
people the girl [ __ ] it up
that injury [ __ ] it up coach [ __ ] it
up blame everybody have everything go
wrong be 57 years old and still have
[ __ ] 40 years to make it right it's
great honestly like if there was some
crazy new drug that I could like inject
in you that gave you perspective of time
you guys to that's the drug I would give
you straight up it makes you optimistic
people sitting here dwelling already
dwelling already [ __ ] shouldn't come
to Rutgers [ __ ] knew it
of course there's people think of that
like that's just real life dwelling
already haven't even [ __ ] started man
that's what I want to change my man
I don't love real estate AJ loves
realist like real estate my opinion
doesn't mean [ __ ] real estate has proven
itself over the last 200 years to be a
wise long-term investment I just don't
get my nut off on it like I don't like
it that much it doesn't but but I would
easily tell you that that's wrong it
just doesn't make me happy but it's a
like if you like it it's a great thing
to lean into but it's about patience you
may come out of school and the market
may collapse cuz its circles you know
everybody
in the world stay with what makes
with
I think because I didn't start talking
until I was 34 and actually accomplished
something
so I wasn't talking in theory I only
talk about [ __ ] I've done which made me
very confident and I only speak about
things I'm doing I think the reason I
feel confident is two reasons one I
watched so much Eddie Murphy and Richard
Pryor and Chris Rock growing up that
somehow I embraced an entertainment
style of when I talk that works and
number two I stay in my lane I only talk
about [ __ ] I know I watched so many
speakers talk in theory talk from an
academic standpoint like they read [ __ ]
I do [ __ ] and then I talk about it like
I'll tell you everything about tick-tock
right now because I do it
so entertainment and not fronting my man
right this second the question is when
do I feel like I had the most leverage
prior to now yesterday you know like
this is my leverage point right like
like I was one of the first hundred
people to have a million followers on
Twitter but it was 2007 and the world
hadn't been on social media yet so when
I repeated it over the last year or two
on Instagram right right now you know
that Instagram blue check that following
count that's currency that's leverage so
right now and my plan my man is to make
the way I just answer you that question
that same answer until the day I [ __ ]
die right now yesterday right now
yesterday but I'm a marathon runner that
kid by the way that came to my dad's
liquor store at 26 and flexed on me
losing life is a marathon everybody out
here is trying to sprint do you rock
that's a good Instagram post let's get
that my man
what's your name Billy I think it's a
game of tasting like the biggest thing I
want for everybody in this room is to
taste [ __ ] like do random [ __ ] like go
skateboard go cook
go try flip life go [ __ ] go [ __ ]
put out a [ __ ] song like I don't
[ __ ] know like taste [ __ ] like in
your 20s you got a taste you know and
and that's the biggest mistake that
people you know like make they're trying
to like figure out everybody's got so
much pressure to like have it figured
out when they come out of school like
it's time to be real in real life and
all that shit's [ __ ] stupid 22 to 30
should be experimenting [ __ ] travel
if you like and people like wild on
money I'm like you can still travel you
can get a [ __ ] [ __ ] plane ticket
you can take a bus like do [ __ ] so I
think you're not gonna find what you
[ __ ] like it's like food I'm always
fascinated by Easter's the amount of
people that think they hate oysters even
though they've never had one I see so
many people living life that way you
don't know your passion cuz they haven't
done [ __ ] Billy how much [ __ ] have you
actually done yet
not much my man so like you got to go
try [ __ ]
not just Billy all you [ __ ] like yeah
you're just happy you're more Billy
right now but it's the same [ __ ]
answer to all of you
you